president of delaware state university
which is a historically black college is
expressing outrage after a bus of his
lacrosse players was stopped and
searched in georgia it happened at the
end of last month when sheriff's
deputies pulled over the bus
as it traveled back home from a game in
florida their bus was initially stopped
for an alleged traffic violation but it
then turned into a search for drugs
members of the lacrosse team say they
were being racially profiled police body
cam video of the incident was released
the reason why i'm studying for a left
lane violation this is the moment
liberty county sheriff's deputies pulled
over a bus of women's lacrosse players
last month after talking to the driver
the sheriff's deputy pokes his head into
the bus race how are y'all doing when he
returns to the car he makes this remark
to a fellow deputy it's a bunch of dang
school girls on the bus it's probably
some weed
maybe the deputies then inform the
driver they're going to search the
luggage under the bus one deputy brings
out a drug sniffing dog they return to
the bus to explain what's happening
there are times where
we end up finding some children that are
missing from their family we find large
amounts of money that nobody knows
anything about
okay or large amounts of cocaine
marijuana heroin methamphetamines
anything like that okay if there is
anything in y'all's luggage we're
probably gonna find it
okay i'm not looking for a little bit of
marijuana but i'm pretty sure you guys a
chaperone is probably going to be
disappointed in you if uh we find any
the deputies proceed to search the bags
going through the women's personal
belongings at one point they pull out a
wrapped gift
what is that i have no clue
your aunt gave it to you you don't know
what it is
i didn't open it i was waiting till i
got back to school i could open it up
she tell you it was she didn't tell me
anything
okay where did you where did you get it
from
georgia
we're gonna open it okay
we're gonna find out exactly what it is
however this is this is the type of
stuff that we look for after around 20
minutes of searching the deputies find
no contraband all right ladies thank you
we're going to get out of here you guys
enjoy the rest of your trip at a press
conference yesterday sheriff william
bowman said multiple vehicles were
stopped that morning and that his
deputies followed the rules the deputy
informed the passengers that the search
would be completed
this is the same protocol that is
expected
to be used no matter the race
gender age or destination of the
passenger he later said this no personal
items on the bus
or person were searched
[Music]
the president of delaware state
university tony allen says the incident
has left him incensed he said quote we
do not intend to let this or any other
incident like it pass idly we are
prepared to go wherever the evidence
leads us we have video we have allies
perhaps more significantly we have the
coverage excuse me the courage of our
convictions totally that's just so wrong
on so many levels and at the end the
officer says enjoy the rest of your day
when you've just been stopped and just
questioned
and humiliated that way
they were all very cooperative they were
all very cooperative because uh they
believe that as the coach of the team ms
jenkins said that uh things could have
gone wrongly very quickly they had not
uh been as cooperative as they were um
the other thing that i just want to
point out that the sheriff's department
says that uh when they pulled the bus
over they weren't able to see who was
inside because the windows were tinted
so so that's just that that's what this
is
right so it's nice
is what it is and if you pull over a bus
fine you might have reason to but once
you get inside i spent four years of my
life on college buses like that going
back and forth as soon as you poke your
head in you know exactly what it is
right and it's no longer a probable
cause
the trauma uh many of these young women
had never had an interaction with police
in their lives and this is the first
interaction that they're going to have
with the police officers in the long
list of people who should be upset about
this the people of georgia should be
upset because your officers have better
things to do what are they doing on that
to say thank you have a nice day how
about you end it with i apologize for
wasting your time exactly all right
thank you vlad we appreciate you we'll
be right back exactly